Je suis Iris Berthomier,
j'ai 33 ans,
je suis membre du Mouvement Démocrate
et je suis élue ici,
dans le 6ème arrondissement de Paris,
et je suis en charge
des questions de handicap,
de santé et d'alimentation durable.
Je suis conseillère d'arrondissement,
ça veut dire que je fais partie
du conseil municipal
à l'échelle de l'arrondissement.
J'ai été élue en 2020
en pleine crise du COVID,
juste après le confinement.
On a hébergé ici,
à l'intérieur de la mairie du 6ème,
un centre de vaccination.
C'est une réalisation
dont je suis très fière.
Il y a évidemment
d'autres réalisations,
je pense par exemple :
on a eu une exposition de peinture
dans la mairie pour mettre en valeur
les peintures réalisées par des enfants
en situation de handicap
qui sont scolarisés
dans le 6ème arrondissement.
J'ai adhéré au MoDem en 2014,
j'étais encore étudiante en Droit
et donc je me sentais proche
des valeurs du Mouvement Démocrate
qui prônait des valeurs de démocratie,
d'attachement à l'Europe,
également la défense de l'idée
d'un courant central en France
qui n'existait pas à l'époque.
Je croyais assez fort à cette idée
développée par François Bayrou
et ça m'a donné envie d'adhérer.
J’ai pris ma carte
sur le site du MoDem
et c'est comme ça que ça a commencé.
J'ai fait des études de Droit,
j'ai exercé la profession de greffière
pendant sept ans à la Cour d'appel de Paris
et à la Cour de cassation.
Je suis maintenant
au Ministère de l'Économie et des Finances,
à la DGCCRF en charge
des questions d'esthétique.
Le Sénat, ça m'évoque la façon
de participer à l'amélioration
de la vie des citoyens,
à la représentation
des collectivités territoriales.
Mais aussi, ça m’évoque
le jardin du Luxembourg, évidemment,
qui est situé dans le 6ème arrondissement.
C'est un endroit où j'aime
venir me promener.
Ma candidature aux élections sénatoriales,
elle est faite dans une démarche collective :
c'est une liste d'union
avec le Mouvement Démocrate,
Renaissance et Horizons,
trois partis politiques
qui sont de la majorité présidentielle.
Il y a un sujet qui me préoccupe :
c'est la fuite des Parisiens
et des familles parisiennes
qui quittent Paris
pour aller s'installer ailleurs
parce qu'ils ne trouvent pas la tranquillité nécessaire
pour y maintenir leurs familles.
Et donc ça, c'est un sujet dont je voudrais
qu'on puisse se saisir
de façon plus globale.
La question de la démographie en France,
mais aussi
dans les grandes villes
et notamment à Paris.
Je n'ai pas toutes les solutions
à proposer clé en main aujourd'hui,
mais en tout cas,
c'est un sujet dont j'aimerais saisir.